PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
We've been talking about
applications of integration,
including finding the
areas between curves.
So I have here a nice
little region that I like.
I think it's kind of cute.
So it's the region
between y equals
sine x and y equals cosine x.
And, you know, those two curves
cross each other over and over
again.
They wrap around each other.
So I'm just interested
in the region
between the two consecutive
points where they cross.
So here, you know,
so at pi over 4
we have sine x equals-- sine pi
over 4 equals cosine pi over 4.
And at 5 pi over 4
they're also equal again,
down in the third
quadrant there.
So, the question is to compute
the area of this region
that they bound between
those two points.
So why don't you take a couple
of minutes, work through that,
come back and we can
work through it together.
All right, welcome back.
So, from this picture
it's pretty easy
to see what the region
of integration is.
I mean what the
bounds on x will be.
As we said, x has
to go the left,
I mean, you could--
sorry, let me start over.
You could do any two consecutive
intersection points you want,
right?
The area is the same in any
case because of the symmetry
of these two functions.
So, OK.
But the first two that are
easiest for me to find are this
pi over 4 and this 5*pi over 4.
So I'm going to do those two.
If you wanted, you
could have done it
with a different pair
of consecutive points.
But, once we've agreed that
sort of these first two
are the ones I'm going
to do, then it's easy.
I know that they're pi
over 4 and 5*pi over 4.
So that's the
interval over which
I'm going to be integrating.
And then, what I
want to do is just
view this region as cut into
a lot of little rectangles.
And I want to integrate the
height of those rectangles
in order to get the area
of the whole region.
So in this case,
the upper curve is
y equals sine x and the lower
curve is y equals cosine of x.
So the height of a
little-- you know
if I draw in a little
rectangle here--
the height of that rectangle
is going to be sine
x minus cosine x.
Its width is dx.
And then I add them
all up by integrating.
So the area is just the integral
from pi over 4 to 5*pi over 4
of sine x minus cosine x dx.
Top minus bottom
to get the height.
If you did it backwards;
if you wrote cosine
minus sine, what you would
get is exactly the negative
of the area.
So it's, all right, from
pi over 4 to 5, pi over 4.
So now, we just have
to integrate this.
So integral of sine, the
function whose derivative
is sine is minus cosine x.
And the function whose
derivative is cosine is sine.
So it's minus sine x between
pi over 4, 5*pi over 4.
And OK, so now, we just
have to plug in the values.
So this is equal to minus cosine
5*pi over 4 minus sine 5*pi
over 4 minus minus cosine pi
over 4 minus sine pi over 4.
And I'm sure you can work
out for yourself that this
is equal to 2 times
the square root of 2
if I haven't botched
anything terribly.
So I'll end there.